reignover the Thanksgiving holiday
largely extinguished the deadly campfire
in Northern California but the wet
weather is bringing with it the threat
of mudslides ends is hampering recovery
efforts the campfire which started two
weeks ago is blamed for at least 84
deaths
475 people are still unaccounted for
the fire also destroyed nearly 19,000
buildings leaving tens of thousands of
people homeless Carter Evans joins us
now from Sacramento this morning with
the story of one man's fight to survive
good morning Carter good morning when
the camp fire basically incinerated the
town of Paradise the most severe victims
were brought here to UC Davis Medical
Center one of them was built Blevins and
well he's thankful he's alive what he
saw will haunt him forever and the
dreams that I've had since I've been
here my god I've burnt so many times in
a fire as his third-degree burns heal
bill Blevins dreams are born out of a
nightmare just over two weeks ago
Blevins was spending the night at a
friend's home in Paradise when the camp
fire tore through town the only way out
was straight through the flames the car
was actually on fire yes my car is
actually on fire what were you thinking
what do we do
what's next run back to the house is the
only thing we could think try to get
back to the house and save the house and
keep it from catching fire if we can
catch that keep the house from catching
fire we might have a chance of surviving
he says running through the fire was the
scariest moment of his life what was the
heat like Oh intense the flames burnt my
face my hands and the flames coming
across the road were like a blowtorch
they used garden hoses to fend off the
flames I was watching all the homes
around us just burned to the ground then
all of a sudden it set in that oh my god
I am burnt bad my hands are like skinned
is melting off my hands I called my wife
and I told her look babe were stranded
we're stuck in the middle of this fire
and we have no way out and I don't know
if the word I'm going to ever see you
again I love you and
I just I don't know if this is gonna be
my last day or not Levin's in his friend
were able to keep the fire at bay long
enough for firefighters to finally
rescue them burns happened fast but they
get better slow dr. tina paul Miera
at UC Davis Medical Center says Blevins
was burned over twelve percent of his
body she estimates his rehab and
recovery will last at least a year he
was a lucky guy he was very lucky not
everybody is as lucky to be able to
escape the flames and and have the
wherewithal to do what he did to get out
I think that we're very lucky to be
alive today because there was a lot of
people that didn't make it out they
perched in their homes or they perished
in their cars trying to get out of there
after Blevins get some painful skin
grafts all over his hands he's actually
hoping to leave the hospital today he's
looking forward to going home and
hugging his wife what he is not looking
forward to is hearing the fate of some
of his friends who lived in Paradise
Anthony Carter Evans in Sacramento with
just another harrowing story out of
California many of them into many people
that they still still are looking for
yeah